la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
il
en blouse blanche et coiffé d'une
charlotte christian et vanessa hoarau
ramasse avec précaution les hauts du
jour toof répondu oui depuis depuis 3h
ce matin elles ont commencé à prendre
ballard orama cela jusqu'à 11 heures est
à fond et après ça sera leur l'ouverture
des trappes pour les poules aller en
plein air depuis deux mois maintenant
ce couple d'éleveurs des hauts de saint
paul a pris de nouvelles habitudes
chaque matin week-ends et jours fériés
compris ils doivent ainsi ramasser les
quelques 7200 eux deux le tout premier
lot de poules pondeuses
le ramassage c'est tous les jours un
très tôt très tôt façon de parler c'est
à partir de nous ses papiers 6h 7h le
ramassage faut compter minimum deux à
trois autant de ramassage pour les
presser de la surveillance a pressé de
faire un toit dans le bâtiment surveillé
regarder contre les lots l'aliment au
niveau des policiers sont pas un
problème ou quoi que ce soit et puis
voilà la surveillance de ces précieuses
hideuse est en effet constante dans le
loyer
christian s'assure que ses poules ne
manque de rien il ya de l'espace est
suffisamment d espace pour elle gambade
et pour jouer par théa ya une zone de
grattage
tu es leçon sur caillebotis pour
l'alimentation et l'eau
moment c'est un bâtiment qui respectent
les nouvelles normes tout ça le gibier
par ce signe avec ce bâtiment tout neuf
répondant aux normes bien-être animal
les poules ont accès à ces points noirs
adapté où elles pourront en toute
tranquillité pondre leurs oeufs
quotidien ah bon
voilà un petit peu le système du pont
d'or à quoi faut le ramassage des oeufs
pour les poules puis ce pont en dessous
on voit le tapis qui circulent justement
avec les oeufs pour partir direction le
sas pour être ramassées et
en dessous là c'est le new c'est que les
poubelles bons cocons le tranquillement
à l'intérieur mais c'est bien à
l'extérieur que les poules de christian
passeront le plus clair de leur temps à
gratter et à picorer sur les trois
hectares de parcours à leur disposition
où il a elle profite de la vie de paul
et profite du soleil du bonheur de
l'espace et là elles peuvent gratter
après trois ans d'études et de
concertation
christian boireau a pu enfin réaliser ce
projet d'élevage de poules en plein air
grâce un partenariat avec la spa du
chemin d'eau également producteur 9
objectif fournir aux consommateurs des
oeufs planaire pays de qualité sont des
heures qu'on retrouve avec le code 1
donc le code de production plein air et
comme disait christian boireau
effectivement on les nourrit avec des
graines de lin et donc on enrichit les
oeufs avec de l'oméga 3 est donc
régulièrement on envoie les yeux à
l'analyse pour contrôler le taux d'oméga
3 oméga 6 et le rapport entre les deux
elles ont quand même un joli parcours et
une jolie vue donc je pense que ça ça
compte aussi
élevé en plein air dans les hauts de
saint-paul les poules le christian
boireau profite ici de conditions
optimales avec notamment un parcours de
3 hectares pour produire des oeufs pays
de qualité sitôt ramasser les oeufs tous
frais sont alors acheminées au centre de
conditionnement située à fleurimont où
ils sont réceptionnés les avions à
parent il ya 1 500 m est comme ça le des
pilotes à prendre dans le bon sens et
regarder sur phaneuf salle où doivent
casser qui s'ensuivront je retiens déjà
un premier contrôle visuel voilà à
l'étape suivante le contrôle visuel et
renforcer au poste de mirage objectif
zéro défaut sur les jeux faits les les
salles
son micro phoenix
voilà le psoe grands lacs sont cassés on
les enlève directement et ceux qui sont
sales on les laisse passer ils vont
passer leur convient doux et ensuite
donc tous les yeux vont être pesées
individuellement par un système de
cuillère en fait et on a un ordinateur
qui va mémoriser le poids de chaque oeuf
est fonction du poids de chaque oeuf on
va l'envoyer dans telle ou telle ligne
et
avant de déposer dans les boîtes on va
inscrire dessus la traçabilité de la
date de compte
ces indications inscrites directement
sur la côte ils permettent en effet
d'assurer la traçabilité de l'oeuf sur
les open air on a donc on mentionne
plein air la dcr pour date de
consommation recommandée donc c'est 28
jours à partir de la date de compte
et puis on vous avez un code européen
donc un ça veut dire que les poules sont
élevées en plein air et 3 c pour les
poules élevées en cage
après vous avez fr puisque le pour le
département la réunion et française
ensuite vous avez notre code éleveurs
donc hc ça correspond aux initiales de
monsieur hoarau christian et puis son
numéro du poulailler qui est le plus lié
numéro un pour la production plein air
donc quand on a la traçabilité montantes
et descendantes puisqu'on pourra
remonter à partir de la grande surface
du frigidaire du consommateur jusqu'à
nous et jusqu'à l'élevage de monsieur
waro et même au delà on pourra remonter
jusqu'à à la naissance des poussins à
l'alimentation qui a été distribué à une
traçabilité totale montantes et
descendantes à la cadence de 30 milles
par heure ce centre conditionnent en
moyenne toutes catégories confondues 80
milles par jour
mais ici comme en métropole les au plein
air sont de plus en plus appréciés par
les consommateurs
les gens s'intéressent de plus en plus à
la qualité de ce qu'il ya dans leur
assiette également au mode de vie des
animaux bien être animal
donc ça c'est des préoccupations que qui
se font jour de plus en plus et ce qui
était à l'époque il ya eu quand on a
démarré une quinzaine d'années vraiment
une toute petite niche ne serait ce
encore une niche mais mais la demande
progresse ce petit à petit le fait seul
le produit animal complètement auto
suffisance on importe madoff à la
réunion de frais et donc voilà on joue
vraiment la carte de la proximité
d'après chen
quand
dans